il m'a fallu 20 ans pour réaliser ma
mission sur terre
je suis le portier
ma mission c'est ouvrir les portes
vous me direz pourquoi pour qui comment
quand
il y a quelques années lorsque j'étais
enfant je vivais au Cameroun pays de mon
essence de ma naissance et un jour alors
que j'avais 12 ans je suis allé à
l'épicerie acheter des boissons et au
retour la bouteille m'a échappé des
mains elle est tombée
j'ai marché sur un tesson de verre je me
suis fait une large plaie à la plante
des pieds une plaie tellement large que
j'ai dû être amené à l'hôpital j'ai reçu
de multiples points de suture j'ai mal
ce jour-là et les jours qui ont suivi
tellement mal que j'imaginais je pensais
un appareil qu'on pourrait tenir dans le
creux de la main qu'on pourrait poser
sur la peau pour faire disparaître la
douleur je pensais à tous ces enfants
dans le monde qui avait aussi des
douleurs physiques ou morales on
pourrait simplement avec cet appareil
mettre sur la peau et se sentir bien
cette blessure m'avait inspiré à devenir
médecin
mon rêve de devenir médecin a commencé
ce jour-là dans ce quartier
où j'ai grandi dans la capitale du
Cameroun
ce rêve était poignant je rêvais
tellement fort et un jour une porte m'a
été fermée on m'a fermé la porte de
l'école de médecine de Yaoundé la seule
école de médecine à l'époque par
corruption par tribalisme je n'ai pas pu
faire médecine au Cameroun
cette première porte m'avait été fermée
je me suis retourné vers mes parents
pour leur demander que fait-on nous
n'avons pas la clé pour ouvrir cette
porte
on a réfléchi on a pensé à changer de
porte c'est alors que j'ai dû aller en
France
pour étudier la médecine
je suis allé en France j'ai étudié et un
jour mon rêve s'est réalisé je suis
devenu médecin
la première porte m'avait été fermée
mais une autre porte était ouverte parce
que je n'avais pas la clé pour ouvrir la
première
cette passion ce rêve d'enfant était
réalisé un jour en France
puis j'ai continué mon cheminement en
France
j'arrive à Besançon c'est une ville à
l'est de la France ou jeune étudiant
pédiatrie je suis un peu perdu je
connais pas grand monde à Toulouse là où
j'étais auparavant j'avais fait mes
études médicales à Toulouse j'avais
commencé à découvrir un lieu qui
s'appelle les poito Habana le port de la
vanne bon danser la salsa où on
s'amusait arrivé à Besançon il n'y avait
rien de ce genre j'ai dû créer ce qui
n'existait pas un soir assis devant mon
ordinateur j'ai composé cette affiche
et dès le lendemain je l'ai distribué
partout sur le campus aux étudiants aux
inconnus en les invitant à mon
appartement
cette affiche des cours de salsa
gratuite une activité bénévole au
service d'une passion j'étais passionné
de salsa passionnés de danse et je
voulais partager cette passion avec
d'autres personnes qui quelque part
avaient aussi la même passion mais
peut-être l'ignorer alors le premier
soir j'ai attendu sagement si personne
son venues en tout cas à la porte
timidement sont entrés ils savaient pas
où ils allaient alors j'ai commencé un
deux trois quatre cinq six je n'avais
aucun talent de professeur de salsa côté
gauche côté droit j'avais fait quelques
révisions sur internet pour apprendre à
faire ces mouvements que j'ai dansé
naturellement ils ont aimé le deuxième
soir la semaine d'après ils étaient
dispute 15 puis 28 30 arrivée à 30 on ne
pouvait plus l'appartement était rendu
trop petit on a du déménager pour
trouver un autre espace
il y avait de la passion il y avait de
la joie il y avait de l'énergie dans le
cœur de toutes ces personnes il y avait
des jeunes il y avait des moins jeunes
tout le monde était content il
partageait quelque chose en commun cette
joie de vivre et c'est ainsi que nous
avons créé salsa mundo
salsa mundo est né de cette passion des
personnes qui avaient envie de partager
une joie de vivre et surtout une
philosophie de vivre
danser pour donner nous avons créé cette
association en 2000 et 20 ans plus tard
elle est toujours présente j'ai passé le
flammeau à d'autres qui continuent cette
mission à ouvrir les portes et partager
à ceux qui veulent entrer
je suis le portier ma mission c'est
ouvrir les portes
mais parfois lorsqu'on ouvre les portes
certaines personnes sont méfiantes il
reste de loin pour regarder nos spa
rentrée
la médecine moderne nous apprend à
soigner le corps et le cœur des
individus mais la médecine a parfois du
mal à nous outiller à comment soigner
les mots m au TS
comment soigner l'environnement mais
pour soigner les mots pour soigner
l'environnement il faut déjà bien lire
les mots bien lire l'environnement
ce bâtiment que vous voyez c'est le CHU
Sainte-Justine il y a un peu plus de 10
ans j'ai été recruté comme médecin
spécialiste et chercheur en pédiatrie et
en épidémiologie
nous sommes ici ce 1er avril à hacher
ses Montréal
un jour j'ai traversé la rue qui sépare
les deux édifices pour venir frapper à
la porte
du MBA Master of Business Administration
les premiers cours les étudiants pour la
plupart qui n'étaient pas du milieu
médical se demander qu'est-ce que
médecin vient faire au MBA qu'est-ce
qu'un médecin peut bien vouloir faire
dans un cours de MBA je savais au fond
de moi qui avait quelque chose qui me
poussait qui stimulait pour aller
chercher cette formation mais ce n'est
que le dernier jour le dernier cours la
dernière et même presque à la dernière
minute que j'ai compris pourquoi j'avais
voulu faire ce MBA c'était pour lire
l'environnement
pour arriver à apprendre à lire
l'environnement et surtout mettre en
pratique cette apprentissage et c'est
ainsi que née la Fondation inspire
formation inspire son organisme à but
non lucratif notre mission c'est aider
les jeunes qui n'ont pas autour de des
personnes pour leur ouvrir les portes
non pas autour de des personnes qui
peuvent comprendre leurs besoins
nous faisons du mentorat nous faisons
des ateliers nous faisons un bout de Cam
annuel et nous essayons de limiter ces
écarts en termes d'équité la Fondation
inspire existe parce qu'on a beaucoup de
bénévoles qui nous aident dans cette
mission pour ouvrir les portes je suis
le portier ma mission c'est ouvrir les
portes
mais toutes les portes ne sont pas
égales il y a certaines portes qui sont
hautes il faut prendre des escaliers
pour monter atteindre la poignée il y a
certaines portes qui sont lourdes il
faut se mettre à plusieurs pour tirer
pour qu'elle s'en trouve et puis à ses
portes vitrées qu'on croit facile à
ouvrir mais qui sont souvent les plus
difficiles le plafond des Verts
il y a aussi ces portes secrètes que peu
de personnes connaissent l'existence et
qui pourtant sont dans la cité au coin
des rues et ses portes qui sont parfois
les plus utiles
et c'est avec tous les mentors de notre
fondation inspire qu'on essaie d'ouvrir
les portes à ces jeunes pour leur donner
les outils pour permettre à ce qu'ils
atteignent leur objectif
en plein début de pandémie en 2019 il y
a une maman qui m'écrit docteur j'ai
besoin d'aide
mon fils
âgé de 17 ans ne respecte pas les
consignes du gouvernement il se retrouve
avec ses amis
elle était très inquiète elle m'envoie
donc ses courriel en demandant que je
parle à son fils son fils a une maladie
de Crohn qui est traitée par médicament
qui diminue son système immunitaire donc
elle avait peur qu'il attrapait une
forme sévère de la maladie elle
demandait de l'aide ce que j'ai fait
j'ai pris le téléphone j'ai parlé à son
fils je lui ai expliqué en d'autres mots
mais derrière cette demande j'ai voulu
comprendre pourquoi les jeunes ne
respectent pas les consignes tu voulais
comprendre quel serait les meilleurs
mots à utiliser pour parler à ces jeunes
soignant les mots et c'est à ce moment
que j'ai réuni les étudiants du
laboratoire pour essayer de réfléchir
ensemble comment on pourrait trouver les
mots pour parler à ces jeunes non
seulement les mots mais aussi les canaux
qui permettraient de leur parler et
délivrer le bon message alors on a fait
une grosse enquête qui a ridicule de
3000 jeunes Québécois et qui a donné des
résultats intéressants qui ont été
publiés dans les journaux scientifiques
mais aussi
dans la presse la radio et on a compris
une chose c'est que le discours et le
langage que les jeunes attendent c'est
différent de ce que le corps médical
avait pour habitude d'utiliser et c'est
ainsi que je suis arrivé sur Tik Tok les
médias sociaux
un médecin sur TikTok après le MBA
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire encore ce
Tic-Toc je suis le portier ma mission
c'est ouvrir les portes
ça c'est la première vidéo
au des cours de ce travail qui a été
fait pour expliquer aux jeunes pourquoi
il est important de porter le masque de
garder la distance sociale on a essayé
d'utiliser les mots qu'ils comprenait et
ce cheminement autour du parcours pour
aller parler aux jeunes c'est quelque
chose qui nous a amené à comprendre que
l'environnement c'est indéterminant
majeur pour la santé la plupart de ces
maladies qu'on connaît repose aussi sur
l'environnement et en étant sur ces
médias un médecin sur les médias sociaux
on arrive à lire à comprendre
l'environnement à écouter la voix
il y a eu depuis le début plus de 700
vidéos que j'ai réalisées il y a eu plus
de 300 000 personnes qui suivent nos
comptes il y a eu des milliers de
commentaires mais ce commentaire en
particulier attirer mon attention c'est
une maman qui écrivait ainsi
je m'abonne direct merci Docteur car
j'étais ignorant je comptais le faire
pour ma fille
âgée de 8 de 6 ans cette maman parlait
de défriser les cheveux et cette vidéo
que j'avais postée expliqué les dangers
en lien avec cette pratique très
courante dans certains populations
noires en Afrique et aussi dans les
Caraïbes
elle avait compris elle avait écouté le
message
ouvrir les portes permet aux personnes
d'accéder à l'information qui parfois
est difficile chaque moyen des milliers
d'articles scientifiques qui sont
publiés et c'est notre mission aussi de
décrypter pour apporter cette
information pour aider les humains à
rester en santé
quand on est le portier on écoute avec
humilité on s'exécute avec grâce et on
s'ajuste avec modestie on ouvre la porte
et on permet à ceux qui sont dehors
d'entrée on les accompagne
vers l'intérieur on les guide
parfois certaines personnes préfèrent
rester à l'extérieur d'autres courageux
aux entrées et trouvent dans ces lieux
un savoir parfois nouveau parfois qui
leur est familier
et tout ce cheminement
tout ce cheminement prend de la
réflexion pour essayer de comprendre
quels sont les éléments les déterminants
qui permettent de faire passer le
message
essayer de prendre conscience de
qu'est-ce qui est efficace et qu'est-ce
qui ne l'est pas et lorsqu'on prend
conscience de ces chemins on agit encore
mieux on agir de façon plus efficace
efficiente et c'est ce qui permet aussi
de se retrouver là aujourd'hui face à
face les yeux dans les yeux ce premier
avril
car alors que j'étais occupé à ouvrir
des portes et des petites des grosses
des grandes des moyennes certaines
portes s'ouvraient à moi je recevais de
plus en plus de clés pour ouvrir
d'autres portes
et c'est ce qui permet d'être là et de
définir aussi notre stratégie de vie
quel est votre stratégie de vie quand on
parle les stratégies on parle de
définir une stratégie
faire naître et faire grandir
et cette stratégie permet de poser des
actions concrètes au quotidien parce que
la mission c'est important de la définir
mais de mettre en pratique c'est ce qui
est fondamental
je suis le portier ma mission c'est
ouvrir les portes
en 2019 j'étais debout face à une
audience lors du gala du repas le réseau
des professionnels africains ici à
Montréal je recevais le prix du
professionnel de l'année et c'était la
première fois que je déclaré
officiellement ma mission
je me mettrai toujours à la lumière pour
éclairer les autres pour guider leur pas
notre métier
c'est ce qui nous permet de vivre mais
notre mission c'est ce qui nous permet
d'exister
j'aimerais vous demander une chose une
seule chose ce soir quand vous rentrerez
chez vous j'aimerais
qu'avant de vous endormir que vous
mettiez une main la gauche sur la droite
dans une poche
et que vous allez au fond de la peau
chercher une clé que vous prenez cette
clé vous l'atteignez fortement au creux
de la main j'aimerais que vous vous
endormiez avec cette clé
et demain matin j'aimerais que vous
ouvrez une porte à quelqu'un un inconnu
à un groupe à une communauté parce qu'on
a tous au fond nous cette clé qui peut
ouvrir la porte à quelqu'un on a tous
ici dans cette salle cette clé on a tous
à tous ceux qui nous écoutent sur les
médias sociaux une clé et si par hasard
la clé n'arrive pas à ouvrir la porte
changer de clé ou changer de porte et
c'est ainsi que ce qui paraissait
inatteignable de vie accessible ce qui
paraissait impossible devient possible
et ce qui paraissait
utopie devient réalité
nous sommes tous des portiers merci
[Applaudissements]